you did this to me you trapped me in
eternity your future self you did this
to me Barry and now the age of my
revenge Rises my freedom is a fan you
will feel my wrath
- laughs OH
the youtubers is Charlie this is going
to be my flash versus avatar speed force
explainer video also have some updates
about what's going on during the break
at the end of this there is a new round
of the flash ring giveaway that's
starting now all you have to do to enter
is be a subscriber and leave a comment
on this video I'm also naming this
week's winner at the end of this video
be sure to click that Bell to enable
alerts so that you don't miss anything
during the break but Savitt are so we've
already learned a lot about him on the
TV show but there's a couple key
differences from the comics they give
little insight as to why he's trapped in
the speedforce even though he calls
himself a speed god but that's actually
a really important point he chose the
name Sava tar for himself the Hindu god
of motion but that doesn't mean that
he's actually a God so as he says you
only need people to believe you're a god
to become a god none of you are on your
knees it's a smart move to bow before
dandy you're not God to be a god you
just have to make people believe you are
no one believes in you so that doesn't
mean that he has like this crazy power
that Barry does not have but when you
look at the comics especially Savatage
storyline there are many different ways
that you can become a speedster you can
gain your power through magic like
through Enchantment like max mercury
back in the 1830s this dying Indian
shaman gave him his speed so you can
also get your power from a speed formula
like the rival of the comics the reverse
flash of the Jay Garrick era the edward
clariss reverse flash they changed that
for the TV show in the comics like way
back in the Golden Age of the flash
during the Jay Garrick era he gave
himself velocity 9 that's how he got his
speed and then like Jesse quick like
Johnny quick you can use the speed
formula to give yourself speed but as of
sabotage debut in the comics they had
only started to learn about the Speed
Force so the people that wrote the flash
comic had a lot of different ways of
explaining how the flash got his powers
but the Speed Force as a concept wasn't
created till mark Wade's run so before
that the flash just ran really fast but
after Mark Waid created the idea of the
Speed Force especially
into this Avatar Ark it changed the
nature of the Flash's powers but you
still have a lot of different types of
speedsters getting their speed from
different sources so what the TV show is
done is it simplified this a little bit
in all of the good speedsters that
you've seen so far get their power from
the Speed Force but they all have
different levels of ability like Wally
West is progressing through his training
much faster than Barry did so just
remember the idea that not all
speedsters are created equal and that
includes
Savitt are so in the comics Savitt are
got his powers when he was struck by
lightning in an aircraft he was a cold
war-era pilot we never learned his name
but when he woke up amidst the wreckage
of his plane he found that he had
SuperSpeed so he killed a bunch of
people took the name sabot R and then
eventually ran afoul of max mercury but
as Max mercury was trying to fight him
he got a taste of the Speed Force and
just went completely drunk on it
he started worshiping the Speed Force as
a god and wanted to commune with it more
and more but because he didn't get his
powers from the Speed Force he wasn't
connected to it in the way that Wally
West was so all he could do was steal
speed from other people that would make
him faster more powerful but there was
an absolute limit so what happens is is
you have all of the speedsters to get
their powers from places that are not
the Speed Force like Jesse quick the
formula speedsters velocity 9 speedsters
anybody else like max mercury that got
it from the Indian shaman Savitt R is
able to steal all of their speed so
Wally West is left to take down sabot R
by himself but one of the key
cornerstones of the Wally West character
is that he had always lived in grief of
how Barry Allen had died and had erected
mental blocks for himself that prevented
him from reaching his full potential as
a speedster so over the course of
several adventures he's able to overcome
this fully tap into the Speed Force in
runs Avatar right into it
trapping him he becomes pure energy Sava
Tarr is trapped in a Speed Force prison
but the reason that he can't get out
is because the nature of his powers do
not connect him with the Speed Force in
the way that wall-e is so he sort of
trapped in this endless void of time and
energy the way they say on the TV show
so what do we know about TV sabotage he
got his powers from the Philosopher's
Stone not directly from the Speed Force
in the way that Barry or Wally got their
powers so the thing about Barry is that
the Speed Force as he spoke to the Speed
Force wormhole aliens in season 2 they
chose him he is like the universe's
champion the way they played it was a
little confusing that's a little bit
different than the comics because in the
comics the Speed Force is just an energy
source in what do you do with energy you
use it to power things there's no
intelligence behind it but the TV show
has turned it into more of a Star Trek
Deep Space 9 thing where you have beings
that exist in this continuum and have a
will they exert it upon the universe
they have a divine purpose and Barry is
an instrument of that but as we've
learned from season two people like zoom
can gain the Speed Force they can get
powers even though these beings did not
choose him as a champion so evil people
can gain speed different ways through
circumstance and that sounds like the
way Savage are got his powers he found
the Philosopher's Stone that gave him
his powers he became super fast he can
siphon speed from other people but he's
not connected to the Speed Force in the
way that Barry is so that's why he can
be so powerful but still be trapped
inside the Speed Force so during the
mid-season finale Jay Garrick made a
really offhanded remark and it was
almost lost like a second time I watched
it I heard it a little bit more clearly
so I'm gonna play this clip it's
actually a really important idea that he
just kind of threw out there but that
stone is loaded with gravimetric force I
mean I don't think you can run fast
enough to reach the speed force and
carry that at the same time
with my help we run as fast as we can
your trail behind me siphon off some of
my speed combine it with your own and
when you have enough throw that thing
deep into the speedforce so here's the
important thing they've kind of done
this before on the flash this isn't the
first time that two people have run
together to enable one to run even
faster than he normally would be able to
run they've done it with the
reverse-flash but here Jay Garrick is
actually saying it out loud in a way
that they haven't done before you can
siphon my speed and that will enable you
to throw the philosopher's stone into
the Speed Force so on the TV show were
already borrowing giving taking speed
between speedsters in a way that's
different from season two where Harrison
wells had to siphon it off using that
special device like it was really hard
for zoom to take Barry's speed but here
he's taking Jay Garrick speed and a
really easy offhanded way like it's no
big deal
so that's actually a huge concept in
what it sounds like is happening here is
that Barry is going to get the arc from
the comics where Wally had to overcome
his mental block so a lot of you ask how
fast is Barry has he reached his full
potential I will say he is definitely
not as fast as he will ever get he will
get even faster by the end of the season
he'll have to in order to defeats avatar
but just like they deepen the mythology
of the flash each new season with each
new villain they'll deepen the mythology
by allowing Barry to more fully tap into
the Speed Force
so he'll become so fast that he can
traps avatar in the Speed Force again
just like they did in the comics so you
just have to remember that the flash TV
show blends a lot of wally west era a
lot of Golden Age era in a lot of modern
era flash so that's why I think that
Barry is getting some Wally West era
comic book story at least as it applies
to the nature of the Speed Force
so hopefully that explains why saboteur
is supposedly a god of speed yet he is
trapped inside the Speed Force when
Barry went there himself I mean he had
to die to do it but I think in the
future he'll just become so fast that he
can go into the Speed Force and come
back out at will but if you guys want I
will do a full flash versa
savat our comic book storyline bonus
video I might have to break it up into a
couple because it's a really big story
but that will happen during the break
I'm doing a bunch of epic comic book
battle videos like the flash versus iris
West is like a really cool twist from
the comics so there'll be all kinds of
bonus videos like that but what's going
to happen later tonight is the
spider-man trailer is going to be
dropping I'm totally going to do a video
for it but they just revealed that
there's a second trailer with slightly
different footage so I'll be doing two
Spider Man trailer videos but the first
one will post later tonight then the
next one will just post Friday morning
so instead of just one spider-man
trailer you get to it's going to be
awesome
there is the mid-season finale of
legends of tomorrow
Captain Cold is back make sure you watch
that episode but because of that
spider-man stuff my video for that won't
post til Friday morning so no worries I
will do legends of tomorrow I will do
agents of shield but because there's so
much stuff happening I'll just update
the schedule as I post new videos so
it's going to be a lot of fun let me
know what kind of flash bonus videos you
want me to do during the break the flash
episode 10 is coming back January 24th
so I know that sounds like a long time
but it's actually not that long but the
flash ring giveaway will still be
happening every week so I'll say
congratulations to this week's winner
mr. Scully please private message me on
the back end of my channel so I can get
your contact details and I did start a
new round at the beginning of this so
I'll announce the winner when I post
that legends of tomorrow video while you
guys wait for that to post you can click
here for the spider-man teaser trailer
and you can click here for my flash
episode 9 video thank you so much for
watching everybody let's high five I'll
see you guys tonight